Can you please explain how blood plasma transfusions work?
Are they good for cancer patients?
So well, there is a difference in whether if you're
doing a blood transfusion for low red blood cells
then you're going to do a whole blood transfusion.
Or you're going to do packed red blood cell transfusion
to help with anidemia.
That would be common with a person with cancer
if they have anidemia.
So they have greatly reduced hemoglobin.
Usually that is the deciding factor
and whether they're going to get a transfusion or not.
You won't get just a straight plasma transfusion.
You get a full blood transfusion or packed red blood cell transfusion.
The negative about getting just a plasma transfusion,
it can be a negative with any blood transfusion
is that you can develop an immune reaction to it.
Not that you're getting the wrong type of blood,
but that you are getting different blood
and it can contain antibodies.
And it can spark an immune reaction, which
can take away from your immune system's ability
if I cancer.
So it's not recommended to get something
unless you absolutely need it.
But you're typically not going to get
a recommendation of a blood transfusion
unless your hemoglobin is 7.5% below.
So it wouldn't even be in the cards.
But certainly, if your hemoglobin is that low,
the clinic or transfusion is most likely
that it's really the best thing to do,
whether you can function, you can keep it over
as long as that.
You're going to have a lot of irregularities
for signs and symptoms.
And I highly recommend it to give transfusion.
But you can't have negative outcomes of getting a transfusion.
It could also be fun, especially as a person
has a core of entity of an immune reaction too.
So you got to do it.